У німецькій домівці, за статистикою, в середньому використовується щонайменше півсотні
електроприладів. Тож німці прискіпливі до вибору постачальника струму.
А вибирати вони можуть серед тисячі компаній. Щоправда, так було не завжди.
Майже до двадцять першого століття ринок електроенергії Німеччини був розділений між кількома,
здебільшого комунальними компаніями. Аж поки у 1997 році Бундестаг не ухвалив новий
енергетичний закон. Завдяки  йому вдалося створити конкуренцію на енергетичному ринку.
На початок 2017 року у Німеччині налічувався тисяча сто п'ятдесят один постачальник струму.
Для того, щоб з'явилися нові компанії, доступ до наявної мережі відкрили для всіх.
Тож нові підприємства  можуть вибирати, в кого купувати струм, та постачати його власним клієнтам вже існуючою мережею.
Хоча монополії серед енергетичних компаній у Німеччині немає, лідери є. Чотирьом найбільшим
компаніям належать близько шістдесяти відсотків енергетичного ринку. Утім, жодна з них
не є монополістом, адже найбільша частка - 21 відсоток.
Нині кожне домогосподарство може обирати, в кого купувати струм. Якщо будинок у сільській місцевості,
то послуги постачання струму пропонують щонайменше півсотні компаній. В щільно заселеній місцевості
місцевості – понад 200. При цьому кожна компанія має різні тарифи. Загалом їх близько 15 тисяч.
За поштовим індексом в інтернеті можна перевірити, які саме компанії постачають
до будинку струм. Тут же можна порівняти, в кого електроенергію купувати найвигідніше.
Не складно в Німеччині і змінити постачальника струму.  Про це необхідно попередити свою компанію
у встановлені контрактом строки. А потім за лічені хвилини укласти онлайн контракт
з новим постачальником. Цією можливістю, до прикладу, минулого року скористалися
4 мільйони родин. Зміна постачальника може заощадити до п'ятисот євро на рік.
Від початку лібералізації енергетичного ринку у перші два роки ціни незначно впали, але з дві тисячі першого року постійно зростають.
В середньому струм в 2017 році у Німеччині коштує 29 центів за кіловат-годину, тобто майже 9 гривень.
Це майже в 5 разів дорожче, ніж в Україні.  Більше половини від ціни за струм –  податки.
Держава обмежено, але таки регулює деякі ціни на ринку електроенергії. Передусім це стосується
відновлюваної енергетики. Закупівельні ціни  на струм, вироблений з альтернативних джерел, встановлені відповідним законом.
Також, щоб не допустити монополії в галузі постачання струму, держава встановлює максимальний тариф
за принципом стимулюючого регулювання. Це спонукає компанії, що володіють мережею, удосконалювати її,
зменшуючи при цьому вартість постачання струму. Тоді вони залишаються у виграші.
Майже 30 відсотків електроенергії в Німеччині походить з альтернативних джерел. Споживачі можуть свідомо
обрати екологічно чистий струм. Утім, це не означає, що до господарства, яке за нього платить,
потрапить саме еко-електроенергія. Коли струм потрапляє до мережі, відділити екологічний від решти,
звісно, неможливо. Однак гроші отримає підприємство, яке купує, скажімо, струм, вироблений вітряками.
Насправді за перехід на альтернативні джерела енергії у Німеччині платять усі споживачі, а саме
близько семи центів з кожної кіловат-години. Серед трендів і "самозабезпечення" струмом,
дедалі більше родин оснащують свої будинки панелями сонячних батарей.